[Music]
I was a young lawyer at the time I get
this call from my boss he said I need
you to see Jeffrey Dahmer
it's my first job I felt like Clarice
Starling in Silence of the Lambs I'm
here to learn from you
maybe you can decide for yourself
whether or not I'm qualified enough to
do that
what to do
the
murders
serial killer Jeffrey Dahmer becomes the
subject of another Netflix project
buried Within Myself for many years in
it we hear the murderer himself through
never before release recordings but also
from those close to the horrifying
Killing Spree there were times that I
felt like a mother to him I felt like I
was a therapist but hearing the graphic
detail was more than I could stand
including Wendy patrickus a young lawyer
tasked with spending over 30 hours
interviewing Dahmer about his crimes I
knew I was sick or evil or both he was
very polite
I was somewhat surprised I guess at uh
how cordial Jeff was
stealing in him that I'm not somebody
sitting here judging him
um was of utmost importance Wendy
recalls her experience sitting face to
face with the killer detailing how she
convinced him to open up to get that
trust
made all the difference in the world but
he called me Wendy and I called him Jeff
the next several months I would spend
considerable time with him
talking about each victim and Gathering
as much information as possible and
here's Wendy in court with the killer
back in 1992 sitting by his side during
this heartbreaking moment
that's surely an unforgettable
experience for the attorney who says
she's still haunted by What Jeffrey did
30 years later I don't think there's
anything that can prepare anybody
for that kind of carnage it was
terrifying to see that this was real the
Polaroids that Jeffrey took I I was
horrified
I had nightmares with it I was just
thinking you know how am I going to get
through this
I don't have anybody to talk to about it
Wendy isn't the only one holding on to
the traumatizing events I knew Jeffrey
Dahmer and several of his victims
there's always going to be that pain
there's always going to be that
remembrance of what happened Michael
Ross and Jeff Connor friends of Dahmer's
victims also shared their experience
with the serial killer they recount the
gruesome murders of their friends
including Tony Sears and explain why
honoring their stories is important like
you're always going to do the what ifs
you know where would they be now and
what kind of Life they have had
you're always going to miss that person
they had a life that they loved
I think it's important to tell their
story
nobody deserves to die like that